hey friends i'm alana and today i
basically wanted to make you a quick
video to talk about um something to do
with the xbox series x that i think a
lot of people may have misunderstood
um i made a video what two days ago now
showing off some of the backwards
compatibility and quick resume and load
times and all that good stuff here on
this channel
and definitely got a lot of comments
from people saying they don't understand
what the point of the quick resume
feature is
um specifically i guess the question is
why would you swap between
three games in a day why would you do
that in any given play session and while
i actually do kind of do that myself i
understand that not a lot of people
um necessarily would do that however
the feature is much broader than that uh
which is what i wanted to demonstrate
today but i also
felt that before we get into this video
i should say a there is going to be a
bunch more
xbox series x coverage on this channel
over the next
i don't know a month probably um because
i have it i'm trying to give you guys as
much information as possible so feel
free to give me these questions uh
genuinely just trying to inform as much
as i can
before you get your hands on one or
before you buy one um
also people asked or expressed concern
in that video when i mentioned that um
master chief collection and i think it
was gears 5
was not yet compatible with the series x
uh
that is basically because what i have is
a preview unit so
it isn't a final product uh some of
these games it seems like it is
especially the
aaa um first party titles are being
properly optimized for the series x
it it shouldn't concern anyone that they
aren't playable on this preview build
uh that is no indication that they won't
be available when the game come sorry
when the unit comes out because i
absolutely believe they will be so
anyway um i think ps5 was actually made
compatible yesterday for example
so they're definitely just rolling those
out um i have my xbox series x here
ta-da it is not plugged in
and i have intentionally had it not
plugged in
for uh 24 hours because i wanted to show
you guys something
so let me plug it in for you guys right
now i'm gonna try and do this video as
well without any editing so you guys can
fully see it all
okay here we go
okay it is plugged in pressing
controller on now let me make myself
smaller
controller i guess did not sync on that
one
but i'm turning the xbox on
okay here we go uh no startup like you
would normally have
from your xbox one x when it has not had
power is worth noting
um and then let's just
jump into ahri shall we
this is the point i am making other way
around it was on the other side
uh quick resume works even if the
console is off
to the extent that you can have the
console unplugged from power
for 24 hours this is my first time
attempting this um
or second actually i had moved it once
and realized that it worked that way
um i'm sure any other game that i've had
open recently
i think fable anniversary should also
quick regime um so basically the point
here is
again this thing was fully unplugged
from power and quick regime still
works uh the point of quick regime is
not
about you in a single play session in a
single five hour block of time
jumping between five games it is about
the people who only play
four games in an entire month having
them
thank you xbox 360 uh interface uh
having them on their home screen
and being able to jump through those
four games
um i would guess probably majority of
gamers play one or two games in a month
obviously i
imagine a lot of people watching this
video would probably be a little bit
more involved in the medium than that
i of course am but my point there is
quick regime works
always um even if the console is
unplugged from power even if it is moved
uh even if you've just turned it off
so that you can constantly access the
games that you are actively playing
significantly faster it's not about
jumping between
four games in one hour it's about
having them there quick resumable you
know if that's a word
uh for a month for a year for as long as
you want
those games are available to you you
don't have to watch the loadings any the
loading screens that that uh the startup
screens rather those aren't even loading
screens in a lot of cases they're just
startup um trailers basically or
advertising
uh for any of the games you frequently
play so that's kind of the point that i
feel like a lot of people have missed um
and i guess you could say like well that
feature's not that cool um you will
absolutely use it is the thing anyone
who plays more than one game will
absolutely use it and
and the feature is cool uh in a way that
i
feel is you know even if i i think it's
crazy that i can unplug this thing and
use it but
even if that doesn't seem like anything
to you i think what makes it cool is
that
quick regime can cut down jumping into a
game
by minutes when you add that up over a
month for the four games you're playing
in that month it can save you hours of
time uh
it is it is a massive time saver and it
is really convenient to have this
series of games that you really enjoy uh
really readily available on the day
where you feel like playing fable versus
the day where you feel like playing ahri
versus the day where you feel like
playing gears versus the day where you
feel like playing halo
so that that's kind of the point that i
wanted to make quick regime is not about
one session it is not about the the five
hour period like i keep saying that you
want to play
uh five games in it is about
always wanting to have these certain
games
available to you really quickly um so i
think it's really neat and really
impressive that it works even when it's
unplugged from power
which is you know the purpose of this
video really was to show you guys that
because when i figured out that that
worked i was like oh damn
that's crazy so yeah that's pretty much
what this video is i just wanted to
highlight that point
of um quick resume is absolutely
convenient for everyone it is not a dumb
pointless feature that you won't use
unless you're a person who really only
ever plays one video game
uh i have have had people ask me to test
it out and how it works with
multiplayer games so i might try that
too i am going to install
gta 5 and red dead redemption 2 as well
just to see how those load times have
improved specifically too
so yeah we'll have some more content
around that but hopefully this sort of
explains the point of quicker game a
little bit better because i do think
general consensus was that people didn't
understand that it worked even after the
console had been
turned off or completely lost power
which is
i think pretty cool
alrighty you guys i'm alana i will see
you next time
[Music]